check out the sparks flying between
Taylor Swift and Tom Hiddleston at her
star-studded fourth of July bash this is
the couple's shot that has everyone
talking it's Superman
Taylor is sitting on Tom's lap the pair
looks like they're about to kiss Blake
Lively and hubby Ryan Reynolds are
posing in the middle and Taylor's
childhood pal Brittney Mac is cuddling
up to her husband on the end
the 26 year olds party took place at her
seventeen million dollar seaside mansion
in Rhode Island complete with an
inflatable red white and blue waterslide
Taylor slid down the giant slide with
tons of her famous gal pals including
Carly cloths and Ruby Rose she also
posed for tons of pigs in and out of the
water here she is with Gigi Hadid and
Cara Delevingne
all in coordinating swimsuits that is
the best kind of friendship you can have
the crew enjoyed playing games watched
fireworks and bundled up fireside and it
looks like Taylor even put on an
impromptu show at some point with Ed
Sheeran and oohs o aduba we're just
wondering how we can score an invite
next year